ON THAT FRONT, STEVE DANES, THE
MONTANA SENATOR, AND LET’S
GO TO BEN CARDIN, VERY GOOD TO
HAVE YOU BACK, SENATOR.
WHAT’S THE LIKELIHOOD WE’RE
GOING TO SEE A DEAL BY LATE
SUNDAY NIGHT?
>> WELL NEIL FIRST OF ALL IT’S
GOOD TO BE WITH YOU HAPPY
HOLIDAYS TO YOU, I HOPE YOU’RE
SAFE.
NEIL: YOU AS WELL.
>> I THINK IT’S PROBABLE WE’RE
GOING TO GET A DEAL DONE I’M
VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT WE’LL HAVE
AN  AGREEMENT REACHED AS EARLY
AS TODAY, AND VOTED ON BY
TOMORROW.
IT’S VERY POSSIBLE, I CAN TELL
YOU IN REGARDS TO THE PACKAGE
THAT I’VE BEEN WORKING ON SMALL
BUSINESS, WE HAVE COMPLETED OUR
WORK, SO I AM OPTIMISTIC.
WE HAVE ONE OR  TWO ISSUES THAT
WERE BUCKED UP TO THE TOP
LEADERSHIP.
THEY’RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ON THAT I EXPECT AS
WE’RE SPEAKING NOW, AND PUT
THIS TOGETHER FOR ACTION IN THE
HOUSE TOMORROW.
I DO WANT TO AGREE WITH
CONGRESSMAN, SENATOR DANES IN
REGARDS TO THE PROCESS.
THIS PROCESS IS JUST HORRIBLE.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE THE
BUDGET UP, THE APPROPRIATION
BILLS UP, THESE ISSUES UP, IN A
MORE DELIBERATE WAY BUT THIS IS
AN URGENT SITUATION.
WE’VE GOT TO GET THIS DONE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE DESPERATELY
NEED THIS COVID RELIEF.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, SO ASSUMING A
DEAL IS DONE, I COULD BE AS
NAIVE OR   OVERLY OPTIMISTIC
BUT TO YOUR POINT THAT A DEAL IS
SCORED DO YOU THINK ANOTHER DEAL
WILL BE NECESSARY THAT ONCE JOE
BIDEN TAKES OVER, HE’S HINTED
THE NEED FOR STILL MORE RELIEF.
ARE YOU IN THAT CAMP AS WELL,
SENATOR?
>> YES, I DO BELIEVE WE’RE
GOING TO NEED ANOTHER COVID
PACKAGE.
THIS IS BASICALLY A TRANSITION
AID PACKAGE TO GET US THROUGH
THE NEXT THREE MONTHS.
WE KNOW THAT THE IMPACT OF
COVID-19 WILL BE BEYOND THREE
MONTHS FROM NOW, THE IMPACT IT
HAS ON AMERICAN FAMILIES AND ON
OUR ECONOMY, ON STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, ON OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM, AND WE’RE GOING TO STILL
NEED TO DO SOME EXTRA WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE RECOVER FROM
THIS COVID-19 AND THE STRONGEST-
POSSIBLE WAY.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, I GUESS THERE’S
BEEN SOME DIVISION ON THE $1,200
RELIEF CHECKS THAT WE SAW BACK
IN THE EARLY PART OF THE
PANDEMIC.
I GUESS RIGHT NOW, SENATOR,
MIGHT BE MORE LIKE $600 AND
AVAILABLE TOFUER FEWER PEOPLE
AND I THINK THE PHASE-OUT WOULD
START AT $75,000 AND EVENTUALLY
RUN OUT ALTOGETHER WHEN YOU HIT
$99,000 IN INCOME.
ARE YOU OKAY WITH THOSE
PROVISIONS AS LONG AS
STIMULUS CHECKS OF ANY
MAGNITUDE WHETHER IT’S 600 OR
$700 GO OUT?
>> REMEMBER THIS IS A
COMPROMISE PROPOSAL IN ORDER TO
GET IT DONE AND SIGNED BY THE
PRESIDENT SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE RELIEF NOW.
IT IS NOT AS LARGE AS I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE PACKAGE.
IT DOES NOT INCLUDE DIRECT
RELIEF TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE DESPERATELY, THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE.
THERE’S NOT ENOUGH RESOURCES
HERE TO DEAL WITH THOSE WHO ARE
UNEMPLOYED BEYOND NEXT FEW
MONTHS, SO WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO COME BACK TO THAT.
THE DIRECT PAYMENT CHECK IS ONE-
HALF THE SIZE AS WE DID IT
UNDER THE CARES ACT BUT IT’S FOR
A SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME AS
FAR AS ITS IMPACT AS TO WHEN
WE EXPECT TO GET THE NEXT
PACKAGE UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, SO YES, I’M
SATISFIED WITH THE PACKAGE.
IT’S NOT THE WAY I WOULD HAVE
PUT IT TOGETHER.
I WOULD HAVE DONE THINGS
DIFFERENTLY, BUT THIS IS WHAT WE
CAN GET DONE AND REPRESENTS THE
VIEWS OF BOTH THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, THE ADMINISTRATION,
AND CONGRESS.
NEIL: CAN YOU USE THIS DELAY
BECAUSE FROM A CAPITAL, SENATOR,
TO TELL YOUR LOVED ONES LOOK, I
WOULD HAVE NORMALLY GOTTEN YOU
HOLIDAY GIFTS, BUT I’VE BEEN TOO
BUSY IN WASHINGTON SO IS IT A
GOOD EXCUSE FOR YOU IN CASE YOUR
LOVED ONES ARE WAITING FOR GIFTS
FROM YOU, THAT THEY’RE NOT GOING
TO GET IT BECAUSE YOU’VE BEEN
TOO BUSY WORKING?
>> NEIL, I’M VERY FORTUNATE,
FIRST OF ALL, I LIVE IN
BALTIMORE SO I GO HOME EVERY
NIGHT AND I HAD TO GET GIFTS
BECAUSE WE CELEBRATE HANUKKAH,
SO YES WE’VE BEEN BUSY IN OUR
FAMILY TAKING CARE OF OUR NEEDS
BUT I’M ONE OF THOSE FORTUNATE
MEMBERS WHOEVER ARE NIGHT CAN
SPEND IT IN MY HOME.
NEIL: THAT’S PRETTY NICE.
THAT’S PRETTY NICE SO THAT
PROCESS IS GOING ON, A COUPLE
MORE NIGHTS, SO ON THE HOME
FRONT, RIGHT?
THEY’RE ALL DONE.
>> RIGHT.
HANUKKAH IS OVER, IT ENDED
YESTERDAY, SO WE’RE NOW IN THE
POST-HANUKKAH PERIOD AND
YOUR POINT IS WELL-TAKEN.
WE SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN THIS DONE
A LONG TIME AGO.
IT’S DESPERATE THAT WE GET THIS
OUT HERE.
WE DON’T WANT THE HOLIDAY TO
BRING THE END OF RELIEF TO THOSE
WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED AND NOT
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES WE NEED TO
GET WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE IN
DESPERATE SITUATIONS, SO WE
SHOULD HAVE DONE THIS EARLIER,
BUT LET’S GET IT DONE IN THE
HOLIDAY SPIRIT AND LET’S GET
THIS COP PLEATED BUT AS
SENATOR DANES SAID THE REAL
GIFT IS THE VACCINE, LET’S GET
THIS PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL
AND PLEASE STAY SAFE, EVERYONE.
WE HAVE A FEW MORE MONTHS WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS DEADLY
VIRUS AND ITS ABILITY TO SPREAD
VERY QUICKLY.
WE ALL HAVE TO STAY VERY
VIGILANT IN DEALING WITH THIS
VIRUS.
NEIL: SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, JUST SHOWING OFF GETTING
YOUR HANUKKAH GIFTS OUT AND NOT
A BUMP IN THE PROCESS HERE AND
NOW I’M REALLY FEELING THE
PRESSURE FOR CHRISTMAS SO
WE’LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
SENATOR, BE WELL, HAVE HAVE A